I say nice to see you thank you so much
for being here thanks rad yeah you know
it's funny you're very young you
probably didn't even know who I was
before you got booked on this show
before you know yeah and I wouldn't
blame you because you don't watch a lot
of late-night television I'm sure know
what but I knew who you were I knew
you're a Conan O'Brien but I never seen
the show before right
but momma was like oh my gosh you never
seen the show before um cuz your mom it
turns out I didn't realize I went no
back and to say hi to you am I your
mom's a big fan of the show she has she
taught you about it at all yes he showed
me I'm a few biscuits well I heard
something about a bear don't look at the
bear thing yeah we don't do the bear
much anymore but just don't watch the
bear yeah don't look at the dog either
just a puppet but you should never look
at the dog yeah so by ditzy in the year
2000 oh yeah we used to do that back in
the day yeah okay which I love you like
that one yeah and you weren't even alive
in the year 2000 no my love saying
[Music]
[Applause]
you have I've on the show black-ish you
have one of the best cold stares in the
world you do it all the time did you
know that you could look that mean we
actually have a still of you from the
show where you just did you know you
could do that before you got this part
well well I was really just acting just
like okay what would Diane do the
Charlie cuz child like Diane does not
like Charlie and Charlie does not like
her sounds like I just do a mean stare
just like
[Laughter]
[Applause]